i don't have a problem with the way that
you deliver things i think you and talib
and james lindsay and is that the thing
is that
the background that you and talib both
have because there is definitely some
similarities in the way that you deliver
your
discourse online yeah that's another
great question uh i think nasim and i
are very good friends for several
reasons one of which
at least if i can speak for him uh in
terms of
you know i always joke that nassim
thinks 99 of humanity
are useless cretins that should be you
know killed
because they're imbeciles beyond
redemption and that i am
one of the few who makes it into his
you're in the cut you're in the one
percent i'm
really in like i i think i think getting
the approval of naseem might be bigger
than a nobel prize
right i mean i say that slightly
facetiously but i think the reason for
that
is because he appreciates in me that i
am
a costly signaling guy meaning that i
walk the walk
i don't give a [ __ ] in the game right so
because of that he respects that and i
also respect that in him
so partly because of our similar
personhood when it comes to that
combativeness
maybe partly because of the middle
eastern thing when you are my friend
i will die for you right so and i won't
get into specifics but i've
i could tell you that when it came to at
certain points
him defending me for something he was
willing to blow up the world
to come in my defense now for many
people we
so for example i have other friends who
naseem despises
and they will say to me they can't
understand why i would be friends
with him right because they see him as
this vile nasty
but the reality is that if you're in his
corner
he's much more likely to fight and die
for you in the trenches
than those highfalutin bullshitters who
would turn away
when you're screaming for help and
pretend that they didn't hear you so i
think because of that trait
uh we're simpatico on that dimension
fair weather friends man no one needs
any of them
exactly why is it the west where these
ideas are proliferating surely
living standards being high should give
people less to complain about not more
so there are several reasons for that i
mean some of it comes from the frankfurt
school that kind of
kicked off some of this [ __ ] stuff
uh some of it is that
you know if i am suffering every day not
knowing if i'm gonna get my
caloric minimal caloric you know food
for the day
i don't have time to pontificate about
feminist glaciology
so in a sense it is a measure
of the decadence of the west right like
it's kind of the caligula effect right
when rome becomes too uh you know imbued
with all of this
hedonic pursuits it kind of
self-implodes so i think there's a
similar thing here where
instead of you know feasting at the
buffet of
gluttony the actual food we're we're
we're feasting at the gluttony of
[ __ ] ideas
because in a sense it demonstrates how
well we have it in the west right
but by the way that's another thing that
really pisses me off because the people
who
the people at wellesley college who are
complaining that they were misgendered
should have lived tuesday morning at 10
o'clock in the morning of my childhood
in lebanon
where i didn't know at 10 o'clock
whether at 10 05
my head would still be connected to the
rest of my body
maybe that's another source of
indignation right when you're constantly
whining
when you simply don't know what else
there is in the world right
that is frustrating to those who have
lived that right so
ayan hershey ali do you know who that is
yeah
so ayan hershey ali should be someone
that people
seriously listen to because she's lived
islam
and yet she is a you know hitler bigot
who
is an islamophobe i mean if a black
woman from somalia
who is an ex-muslim is somebody that
doesn't carry the right
identity markers to speak about islam
then we're lost right
so i think that's another reason of my
indignation and that is that
boy are you sheltered when you complain
about the things that you do in the west
[Music]